hey everyone today I'm going to show you
inside a physics exam I know that some
of you might be interested to know
exactly what studying physics is like
and therefore what sort of exams and
assessment looks like so I have here a
theoretical physics exam and I will say
as a disclaimer the questions in here I
have edited so that they're not exactly
the same as an exam I took although it
is based on a real exam I've done this
for two reasons one so that my uni
doesn't arrest me for publishing a real
exam and two is so that I can give you
guys some solutions as well that I sort
of fully worked and available elsewhere
online and like textbook solutions
having said that it does cover the same
ideas that you would expect and that I
definitely saw when I took an exam like
this for the first time now the exam
I've replicated as a theoretical physics
exam from a third-year University course
and it would take you three hours to do
this exam and there are four questions
so let me show you what it looks like
so this exam is going to cover most
areas of theoretical physics that's a
bit of classical mechanics and quantum
mechanics and special relativity so
let's have a look first up we're going
to have a classical mechanics problem
and this is one that deals with a
Lagrangian so we've actually got a
double pendulum here and this is
probably a bit of a typical problem so
you're given a double pendulum and
you're asked first of all to find the
Lagrangian so that's essentially a way
of finding out how to describe the
system when the system is quite
complicated then you want to find the
equations of motion that's probably
where you're going to get a lot of marks
as well because they might be a bit
complicated and there'll be a lot of
calculus involved
then you're asked to describe the
properties of a chaotic system that'll
be saying something like a chaotic
system which a double pendulum is well
small deviations and where it starts or
in the initial condition can lead to
vastly different outcomes over time and
then lastly for this question we've got
explain the significance of know--this
theorem moving on to part two now we
have a quantum mechanics problem so this
is actually from Griffiths
a really good quantum mechanics textbook
and it's about time and dependent
perturbation Theory now often when you
work with quantum mechanics problems
you're dealing with say a particle in a
infinite square well but perturbation
theory deals with if there is a sort of
blip or a bump a perturbation in that
square well so it's no longer just a
perfect square have a look in the
description and I will link the solution
here of how to do this our third
question is also a quantum mechanics
problem it's stealing with some sort of
identities commutator relations and
really it's a whole bunch of proofs when
I was doing sort of this exam getting to
this page the page of quantum mechanics
proofs and just show things is where my
heart sinks because those are to me the
hardest questions using mathematical
induction or otherwise show that this is
true the classic or otherwise statement
means really do it using the way they
mentioned at the start otherwise you've
got some crazy idea up your sleeve I
don't know you maybe if you're clever
you can think of another way to do it
but usually when they give you a hint
like this it's a good idea to go with
the hint part see I would probably find
pretty tricky in this exam and it's
showing a relation that's got something
to do with Aaron's first theorem I don't
know how to pronounce that
I barely remember that
hyrum but i know this has got something
to do with it and then Part D we're
finishing off with a question about spin
the spin question really comes down to
using linear algebra and it's a useful
application of some of the maths you
learn quite early on so finding a
normalization constant and expectation
values lastly we have one whole question
about special relativity what makes
special relativity difficult and say
third-year it's not the idea of sort of
time dilation and length contraction but
it's moving into using tensors and
describing things in four space so
that's you can see this little notation
here with the Greek letters
that's called a four vector and it can
be pretty tricky and being obstacle to
actually describing sort of space-time
and special relativity so because of
that and because you would have just
learned how to use these four vectors
most of these questions here are just
sort of kind of manipulation of four
vectors and once you really master these
I think you might be able to go on to
being good at things like general
relativity and really getting into
deeper into theoretical physics concepts
that isn't the road I went down but I
think they were still pretty cool to
learn about I hope no one gets too
stressed out looking at this exam that
I've showed you because whilst this is
pretty realistic of what you can expect
if you haven't taken the course and
subjects that are relevant to what I'm
showing you it can probably look
overwhelming even me looking back on
this now I'm like geez how did I do any
of this I can't remember some of this
stuff now but when you're in that
mindset of learning and studying for a
course and then it's not so alien to you
then this something like this would feel
I don't know possible if you actually
immersed in that environment and you've
done the work leading up to it thanks
for watching and if you have any
questions about this exam or what others
might look like please let me know